it so happens that you've been selected
for the dear moon mission that will fly
Starship once around the Moon with nine
people on board
uh you are one of those people so
just pause to take that in
everything that we've been talking about
you will not just be reporting on you'll
be a part of it
so tell me about the objective of this
Mission and um how does it feel to be a
part of it
well
[Laughter]
man
yeah yeah it's
basically
it's the Willy Wonka of space like
generous yeah a generous individual
purchased a ride from SpaceX as early uh
at least as far as I know the earliest I
knew about it was February 27 2017.
who's the individual uh you sakumizawa
but at the time I'm telling a story at
the time we didn't know okay great great
so February 27 2017 a press release
comes out from SpaceX saying someone
purchased a ride
through us around the Moon
we're gonna fly someone around the moon
and at the time was on a crew Dragon
capsule and a falcon heavy it's like wow
and that was enough that little moment
right there that press release it's the
first time I'm like I'm gonna make a
YouTube video about this and I stood up
turn on my camera put on my at the time
spacesuit and I basically yelled at the
camera for three minutes about someone's
going around the Moon you know
fast forward to 2018 uh end of 2018 or
near the end they introduced there's a
SpaceX press conference I'm I'm there as
a member of the press I'm reporting on
we're going to meet this person that's
going around the moon and come to find
out boom they're going to be riding on
Starship now they change from Falcon
heavy and Dragon SpaceX is no longer
going to do that they're going to
upgrade them basically to Starship so
instead of being in like a small Tin Can
they're in this giant luxurious you know
Mega rocket around the moon and it comes
out this individual named usakumayazawa
who is a Japanese billionaire uh
purchased this ride and instead of
inviting you know his friends and you
know colleagues and whatever whoever's
family members or whatever
he decided the the most impactful thing
he could do with this opportunity is
invite
uh more or less artists in the original
thing it was like artists you know
journalist a painter a an athlete a you
know a all you know photographer
videographer you know all walks of life
basically when they said athlete they
thought of you they're like I know a guy
this guy rode Ragnar once
uh but uh so and at the time you know I
was like this is crazy I can't believe
this is gonna happen and you know he had
this this vision of we're gonna find
people from all around the world I'm
going to invite people from all around
the world
um from different walks of life
different different you know trades and
I'm going to share this experience so
that they can share it with the world
and really have an impact much greater
than you know any one country or any one
individual or any you know set of
military trained you know astronauts
could could do offer up A New
Perspective
beautiful I literally I mean at the
press conference I I cried like I had a
couple tears in my eyes I was like this
is so so we could just pause on that so
he goes by MZ MZ yep
how incredible is that it's I like uh I
I think it's
you often don't realize the importance
of individuals in human history like
they they Define because this this could
be we were talking about the importance
of Elon in particular you know most of
the work is done by large groups of
people there are collective intelligence
that we band together but like these
individuals can
be the spark of the Catalyst of that
progress and I mean just this idea of
getting
not just civilians which is already
incredible but civilians with a sort of
an artistic flame that burns inside them
they're able to communicate whatever
they do are able to communicate
something about that experience and it's
just a genius idea to spend quite
probably a very large amount of money
for that I mean it's uh it's it's it's
it and it does and that will be part of
History yeah and it's easy these days
for people to be cynical you know
especially about like space flight and
Wealthy individuals but really in my
opinion and maybe you know just the time
I was just so couldn't believe this this
idea
you know I'm someone that has studied a
lot about you know the Apollo program
the people that have been to the moon
and they're incredible individuals
incredible individuals but they're so
saturated with tasks you know and
they're military trained and often
um that they didn't really have the
luxury of just being able to soak in the
experience of going around or to the
Moon
and seeing the Moon up close with your
own eyes like that just psychologically
has to be insane
and so to have this opportunity to be
able to observe our closest Celestial
neighbor with their own eyes and your
sole purpose is to soak it in and share
it and communicate and create
with the rest of our planet like that to
me is just beautiful
so that is the objective of the mission
that right there is the objective of the
mission and how does it feel to be
selected as uh one of the nine to do it
it's it's it's a it's a gradient it's
slowly it's doing a few things
um since I've known it's become
um I think the closer it gets the more
excited and the more nervous I get
you know it's a more real it becomes the
more real it becomes you know the
announcement was a big uh it just got
announced at the end of 2022 publicly
um who's involved and so you know prior
to that like I had you know each step of
the selection process you know there's a
pretty comprehensive selection process
with interviews and stuff each each step
I would try not to get my hopes up and
frankly like this let me be clear this
was not something that like I've always
wanted to do you know it's not like I'm
out there I didn't start doing YouTube
videos because I wanted to even go to
space like none of that I and I've said
hilariously I probably said dozens or
hundreds of times on air like yeah I
don't ever want to go to space because
it's not like my it's not a driving
force it's not really a thing I even
really truly pictured or let myself
fantasize about frankly
so each step of the selection process I
didn't really let myself dream about it
too much or you know but it kind of it
would kind of chip away like oh my God
this is actually becoming more real this
is actually more and more of an
opportunity and I get equally more
nervous too like you know frankly it is
it's I've you know I've seen space
flight stuff go wrong I've you know I
think about this stuff a lot so like
yeah I get more nervous but I also get
more excited about that opportunity like
it's an opportunity that how can you
pass it still I still have to actually
stop pause think
and actually realized the reality that
like that I am going to the Moon I'm
going to see the Moon up close uh flying
around the Moon I'm sorry some people
get mad when I say going to the moon
since I'm not landing on it
um but flying around the Moon seeing The
Far Side of the Moon with my own eyes
and seeing Earth
and seeing the Earth rise behind it yeah
it's going to I just I can't I can't
tell you what it's going to be like and
feel like so epic but it's insane to me
that like we're having this conversation
that that is my my reality you know like
and that someone was generous enough to
consider the option of sharing this with
with frankly strangers yeah and the the
process that they had for selecting like
how
um how much thought and time went into
the selection process is incredible you
know they did a public call at the
beginning of 2021. and so the teams
involved in in whittling it down from a
million applicants there's a million
applicants and they got it down to to
eight crew members and and two backups
yeah
um amazing people I would have you know
I don't know how they wound up where
they did but it's it's incredible I I
feel a very deep connection to everyone
that's already involved in what can you
say about the crew you've gotten the
chance to meet them and talk to them I
know Steve aoki's on on the crew like
well who else who else is there so uh
you are obviously the the star athlete
who else in terms of the the artists
that are there so oh man we might just
want to pull up just so I don't totally
Butcher and forget anybody but because
so far I haven't actually had the chance
to meet everyone in person you know so
far a lot of this was done during the
pandemic but we've met through a couple
different things we've had a couple
different times to get together but so
so far I have not met Steve Aoki yet or
top
um we've been on calls and stuff I also
have not yet met uh Dev Joshi who is an
actor from India so yeah I mean Steve
Aoki American uh DJ and producer and
musician top from South Korea is also a
musician and a producer so it's all
across the world is a truly Global uh
all different kinds of walks of life
yeah all artists of different forms and
Steve is is Japanese uh his parents are
Japanese but he you know lit born raised
in the United States uh yemi is a dancer
and choreographer from the Czech
Republic uh Rhiannon is a fine art
photographer from well England in in
Ireland I guess she lives in both in
kind of a bit of a she's all over the
place Technically she's Irish I guess uh
I Tim Dodd yep that's me from the United
States uh uh then you have Kareem who is
from England and does also as a
photographer and documentarian uh does a
lot of work with oceanography and uh
volcanoes so he does really incredible
work Brendan Hall is a documentarian and
filmmaker Deb Joshi sorry Brendan is
also from the United States Deb Joshi is
an Indian actor
I believe also I believe he's also
already been producing and things he's
very young I think he's only like 19 or
20 and he's I mean he's been acting
since he was like five years old or
something he's a he's a Bollywood star
like he is a star in India which is
really cool right
um Caitlyn Farrington from the United
States is an Olympic gold medalist
snowboarder
so she believe it or not is the athlete
not me
and then uh and she's one of the backup
crew members as as so is uh Miu from
Japan who's a dancer
oh it's amazing I mean it's such an
interesting group I mean can you is
there something else you could say about
MZ how about you you sakamaizawa so he
uh he's also a musician so he was
actually in like some kind of punk
hardcore Japanese bands in the early in
the 90s and stuff and early 2000s he
started a um a record company and and
distribution and sales ended up in in
fashion and um owns one of the biggest
fashion companies in Japan and has
become a fine art collector and just
kind of a philanthropist and and he's
been out to space already he's already
not only been to space like you know
he's been to the International Space
Station he's been on orbit and on the
ISS and so he what's cool is like you
know there's talks of when there's then
frankly to be to be honest and we still
don't I still don't know all of the
details about this you know we're not
yet into training I kind of always
assumed prior that there'd be some
professional astronaut you know when
they talked about in 2018 there's talks
of we'll have a professional astronaut
on board
but realistically now like MZ is a
trained astronaut you know he has
trained a lot like six months you know
plus to be able to fly on soyuz so as
far as like it's good to know for me
that I have someone
on the crew that has experience with
space flight
um has trained and has some knowledge on
space flight as well you know that's
that is an important aspect for sure so
you made a excellent video about flying
in the fighter jet uh that I think you
mentioned may be relevant uh to the
training is there some high level
aspects to training that you anticipate
that you might be able to speak to yeah
so you know so far I think we can really
lean on what has happened with the other
um you know commercial crew missions and
in in private missions like the
inspiration form Mission or Axiom uh
where SpaceX flew individually they
trained for about six months a lot of
like reading manuals and learning the
spacecraft are you gonna do like a Rocky
4 Montage or
a lot of physical training and they're
like we didn't tell them to do it he's
just seems to want to film himself
shirtless in the snow it doesn't make
any houses always doing this I can't get
him to stop punching me
um so yeah hopefully uh
realistically
I like it but there's there's a physical
component to all of this and that's
that's really I mean that that's
fascinating it's also inspired in the
sort of civilians
can do this that's that's really
interesting yeah I mean this is and to
me this represents this and the other
commercial space you know uh private
space flight missions like this
represent really a turning point like
truly an inflection and again it's easy
for people to be cynical that
oh you know why are people wasting all
this money doing space flight stuff it's
like well I'm sure some people were
saying that same thing about you know
airplanes and and early Aviation going
like why are we I can't believe those
people are wasting the government's you
know funding these stupid planes and
stuff how's this ever going to benefit
me and nowadays like imagine if all the
planes just stopped working like would
freak out like our economy would
collapse yeah it would suck you know and
I you know might be a long time before
we get to that reality with space fight
well no if if spaceflight halted today
you know space assets uh all of our you
know on-orbit assets our life would be
crippled and I don't think people
realize that yeah so it's already we're
already reliant on it but now we're
getting to the point where it's we're
really turning that corner where it's
the average person alive today you know
if you're born uh you know now or from
now on I think there's a real decent
chance that by the time you pass There's
an opportunity to have flown in space
yeah I mean I if I'm being honest I
still haven't lost the the feeling of
magic of flying in an airplane I often
catch myself thinking like how's this
real
how is it and like
the contrast of this incredible thing
that's incredibly safe flying through
the air taking off and Landing while
everyone else just looks bored
watching like I don't know uh some
romantic comedy on their phone with
Wi-Fi yeah so yeah it's just it's like
the contrast of that is like wow we're
we're incredible we're incredible as a
society and it's like we we develop some
amazing technology that improves almost
the measurably our quality of life and
then we take it for granted and now
still reach for the next thing and the
next thing in life becomes more
beautiful and complex and interesting
and yeah it's just the same stuff will
be uh happening oh yeah uh with space
travel oh it'll become mundane and
boring at some point the tough thing
about space travel of course
uh you know I don't even know if it's
such a giant leap over airplanes because
airplanes are already incredible but uh
the tough thing with space travel is the
destination right is the is the is the
landing on a whole lot of the worlds
well there's docking with with different
transport vehicles or the space station
or it's Landing elsewhere I mean it's
it's it it really really is incredible I
I think you mentioned since there's uh
there's artists there's filmmakers and
so on
and you're all of those
on top of being a great athlete I don't
know I'll just stop the running joke at
this point uh but is there have you uh
thought about
um just just in general like we've
offline talked about microphones and
like all the different ways to film
space launch uh for the rocket launches
uh have you thought about the different
options of like how to capture
how to capture this uh uh have you have
the team have been like brainstorming
and thinking about this do you
anticipate it being super challenging
because there's so many opportunities to
sort of think of how to do this so one
of the fun things to remember is that
Starship is huge like its internal
volume is uh the pressurized volume on
Starship is is bigger than a 747's
pressurized volume and it can take 100
metric tons to anywhere with enough
refueling 100 so we have in theory very
little mass and volume constraints
unlike prior all other space flight
missions ever you you think you're
counting you know grams down to you know
and just really can't risk you know you
have very defined parameters on on what
you can and cannot do
we're going to likely have the luxury of
being able to film and capture this in a
way that's just never been done before
you know we won't be inhibited by mass
and volume constraints like prior yeah
so
all that said and done I'm hoping that
we'll be able to just arm ourselves to
the teeth with the absolute best cameras
and Equipment possible backups on
backups and you know on pre-wire you
know like pre-rigged things Starship is
going to be a transportation system and
it has you know it's being built from
the ground up there's no reason why they
can't
put infrastructure in for cameras that
are just housed in the vehicle you know
um these are talks that I'm excited to
have because I really ideally one of the
things I'd love to do I'm going to be
pushing really hard to actually try live
streaming
from inside during the launch
during the launch live stream from the
inside that would be incredible wouldn't
that be
it's possible to pull off that's really
really incredible now there is the magic
to the live stream because like that's
real that's right there that would the
world would tune in that would be truly
inspiring yes to me that's one of those
things a lot of people ask why they
aren't doing it of course NASA and other
individuals have their reasons of why
not you know there's obviously some
technical hurdles but now with starlink
and other capabilities there's
less hurdles there's obviously some
transparency reasons why you know on
safety reasons why it might not be a
great idea to live stream a risky rocket
launch you know the Challenger I think
put a pretty bad
tasting our mouth as far as publicizing
an event and having every student in the
United States tune in to you know
tragedy but
um that's something I'm pushing for
really hard just because I think it
could be magical I think it could really
connect with people in a way that hasn't
been done before speaking of Challenger
have you thought about the fact that
you're riding
a thing as we've been talking about
that's
um
that's a giant explosive powerful rocket
have you um
have you thought about the risk of that
the danger of that
have you contemplated your own mortality
how could I not you know I've seen with
my I've seen and felt
four of these prototype Vehicles blow up
you know with my own eyes
um I don't know if there's anyone else
you know early days some of the you know
Mercury and Gemini astronauts watched
failures of rockets and then got on them
I don't know of too many people that are
dumb enough to do that though these days
this day and age
um it's it's obviously I will have to
see a lot of successful launches and
have to have a lot of
confidence and in the engineering the
data that they've developed a safe
system because currently the current
iteration of Starship Has No abort
system has no
Escape Tower so you know Dragon capsule
which is currently flying people has a
launch abort system it has super Draco
engines that
either by the push of a button or by the
automatic triggering of the flight
computer can shoot the the capsule off
of the rocket in milliseconds and pull
it safely away get it far enough away
that it can pull the parachutes and
safely splash down
um Starship by all iterations I've ever
seen does not have that the space
shuttle also did not have that so it's
not absurd to not have an abort system
like it is there is you know
certain engineering principles that that
prove that that could be a completely
valid thing you know the space shuttle
through 100 flew 133 times fully
successfully it did have two failures
resulting in the loss of 14 lives
85 or sorry 98.5 success rate
pretty I mean yeah you there's other
I've probably done things that are a lot
riskier I have race motorcycles drag
race motorcycles and you know ridden
like an absolute jerk on the streets on
a motorcycle I'm sure I've had a higher
than a 98.5 percent survival rate or
lower than that I mean at some point
um
so it's a you know yes it's it's risky
it's scary
and um
I think about it a lot a lot it
definitely is one of those things that I
you know I I will have to see and I'm
I'm in no hurry for this to happen
either you know personally I'm in no
hurry because it's like I would rather
see this thing be developed and iterated
and see 10 you know or I was gonna say
ten dozen but I'd be happy with a dozen
fully successful like oh we've got this
thing totally nailed down uh you know
before I get on it
but and that that likely is the reality
there will likely be a dozen or two or
three launches because just even to get
to the moon on Starship they have to
refuel it in orbit
um so it will arrive get to Earth orbit
basically empty and out of fuel so I'll
have to dock with a fuel Depot
and then go to the Moon so
just even get that full you know we're
already talking about a lot you know a
handful of launches so there will be a
lot of launches before we fly would they
do a test flight without humans on board
that goes to the moon or no I'm not sure
I'm not sure if they'll do that exact
flight profile but by then they will
have already flown most likely the
Artemis 3 program will have flown a
Starship variant to the Moon that lands
on the moon
um
so doing at that point you're pretty
much I would like them to test the heat
shield of that entry velocity though
because it is uh you know it takes
another it's about 30 percent faster to
get I get to go 30 faster than the low
earth orbit to get out to a translunar
injection and although that only sounds
like oh 30 faster it's you know the the
re-entry heating experienced by a
vehicle goes up by velocity uh cubed not
squared so not even not linear so it's
not if you go twice as fast you get you
see twice as much you know 30 faster 30
more heat it's and it's not squared it's
not go twice as fast get four times as
much heat let's go twice as fast get
eight times as much heat on re-entry so
30 faster on re-entry is actually a
really really big deal
so I would love to see that because you
know there's certain things that I would
love to see Milestones that I would love
to see tested out and proven
um before I get on board but
at the end of the day I really do
believe that um just like Falcon 9 and
the success of that that they're going
to push it and get all the The Kinks out
well before anyone's on top of it
nowadays Falcon 9 and dragon is you know
arguably the
one of the safest most reliable
and best rides you could take to space
are you afraid of dying
yeah yeah is this one of the first times
you get to you're young yeah have you
gotten a chance to think about death is
one of the
first times you've really contemplated
it
I mean yeah I mean
like I said I've had I've had dumb
moments on motorcycles where I kind of
saw you know like I'm going to smash
into this thing at 120 mile an hour and
I so you've had moments when you realize
it could end just like this yes were you
literally and I've I have for most of my
adult life had dreams of
falling and hitting the ground and it's
just all you get a ring in your ears it
all goes black and in my head I go oh
[__] that was it have you seen a
therapist about this or no I wonder what
it means
I'm sure there's a Freudian
interpretation someone in there but that
I'm going to also apply to my dating
life no the joke is it's the running
joke continues okay so um I mean it's
um it's fascinating in general as I hope
we'll talk about in the early days of
space flight that there is there is a
the task of reaching out to the stars is
a fundamentally risky one you have to
take risks and of course there's really
rigorous safety precautions and so on
but it still is still a risk well and I
think like most people that that for me
the idea of dying isn't so much about
myself it's about those affected by you
know my my loved ones my family you know
my girlfriend my my friends you know
obviously I don't wanted
have this be a traumatic experience for
anybody you know it's already gonna be
hard like it's already I know uh my mom
gets my parents and and family and
friends are very supportive
um and you know my parents are you know
all about it of course but my mom is
also very emotional too so you know
she's so my speaking of athletes my
brother-in-law's actually been on
American Ninja Warrior two seasons
um phenomenal athlete and even just when
he competes my mom gets so emotional
like she can't even hold it together
seeing that so what's it gonna be like
when she sees her son get on top of a
skyscraper and and Ascend on a column of
flames into the heavens like that's
going to be very difficult you know
um
and I I've you know I've taken them out
they've seen they've seen Starbase and
they've seen Starship they've seen a
couple launches I don't know if that's
gonna make them feel better
therapy I guess exposure therapy okay uh
have you had that conversation with them
about this like before agreeing
uh to join I mean was was that what the
what's that or is it one of those things
like
uh you just you don't have that
conversation I suppose it's understood
that there's a love there's a passion
here and and realistically I'm not
uh I'm going to be
convinced and statistically convinced
that this is relatively safe you know
like again in the in the 99s percent
safe yeah again there's things that
people do every day that are
less safe than this you know like you're
riding a motorcycle again yeah riding
Morsi doing wheelies at over 100 mile an
hour not you did it really is over 100
what what
all right I'm not a smart guy always
okay
well you know formation flying in the
fighter jets was likely a more dangerous
thing yes then
what I'll be doing in space flight